[Music]
we're gonna sink you some Christmas
songs
dashing through the woods dancer Prancer
vixen in Cupid and Donner Blitzen
but do you recall love the red-nosed
reindeer had a very shiny nose and if
you ever saw it you would really say it
glows all of the other reindeer used to
laugh and call him names they never let
poor Rudolph
[Music]
Noro bride won't you guys thank the
holes with lots of holy love Allah Allah
Allah Allah tis the season to be jolly
[Music]
[Applause]
say Merry Christmas thanks for watching
guys we hope you have a Merry Christmas
and if you'd like to see more great
videos from the other boys YouTube
channel don't forget to
I don't forget bland sound scratchy
nailed it